in terms of cell signaling calcium is
one of the most important second
messenger molecules our life starts with
the unitary event of fertilization
underlying fertilization there is a
spatial temporal dynamics of calcium
waves which is generated so our life
begins with a wave of calcium right now
once our life form is generated it need
to maintain the life form the heart need
to beat in an organism right and even
underlying the heart beating there is a
calcium dynamics which generates the
cardiac action potential so calcium
waves is pretty important for all the
life processes now calcium is important
this thing is not new people like Sidney
ringer in 1880 s
know that calcium was pretty important
one day signaling her was performing a
nice experiment where in a tote he was
trying to make solutions which can make
toad heart beat in an artificial manner
so every solution was failing up
suddenly one day instead of putting
making the solution in distilled water
he put tap water and suddenly he saw
that the heart started beating instead
of stopping the heart started beating
and now we know that that time London
tap water was highly contaminated with
calcium salts and that led to the
discovery of ringers solution that till
now we are using so from that experiment
we can understand that calcium is
important for physiological processes
now calcium is important for muscle
contraction secretion metabolism
fertilization neuronal activity neuronal
plasticity cell division phagocytosis
cell motility and many more aspects of
the cellular physiology so not only
calcium concentration or calcium as a
molecule but the way the cell perceived
the calcium levels are
also important so the spatial and
temporal dynamics of calcium signaling
is important let me give an example for
example there are several calcium
dynamics which lasts for a few
milliseconds and for a few milliseconds
there is a huge increase in calcium
level that leads to potentiation of
synaptic efficacy in neural networks
whereas a slow calcium dynamics which
persist for several hours two days
can give rise to depression in the
synaptic efficacy other reports suggest
that long-term elevated calcium level
can give rise to homeostatic synaptic
scaling and try to maintain the calcium
homeostasis in the neuron whereas
falling down of the calcium levels from
the baseline can give rise homeostatic
synaptic upskilling which would also try
to make the calcium which can also try
to maintain the calcium level inside the
cell so how the Kell what is the spatial
and temporal aspect of the calcium
signaling is perceived by a cell is very
important so let's just try to
understand which aspects of the cell
signaling calcium is important in and
how calcium is sensed inside the cell so
here is a ligand which is binding to its
g-protein coupled receptor and in this
case it's a GQ coupled receptor so the G
alpha Q subunit gets activated and it
activates phospholipase C phospholipase
C can interact with membrane lipids such
as p2 which ultimately give rise to ip3
inositol triphosphate now ip3 binds to
the ip3 receptor on the endoplasmic
reticulum which leads to increase in
calcium level in the cytosol the sudden
increase in the calcium level in the
cytosol can be sensed by calmodulin now
calmodulin has four calcium binding
domains and it can bind to the calcium
now once
calmodulin binds to the calcium it can
signal other kinase other cases also
exists where calcium increase lead to
activation of calmodulin and calmodulin
lead to activation of
phosphorylase a phosphatase enzyme which
break down phosphatase like calcineurin
calcineurin then cleaves a phosphate
phosphate group from nfat a
transcription factor now nfat gets
localized into the nucleus when calcium
level is increased and this whole
response is triggered by calcium
dependent phosphatase so calcium
dependent kinases and phosphatases play
a vital role in cellular signaling
pathways now you might wonder that how
inside the cell calcium level could be
sensed so there are several decoder
molecules such as calcium dependent
kinase to camp k4 etc which can sense
the spatial and temporal aspect of a
calcium signaling and accordingly they
take decision what to do and what
downstream target to phosphorylate now
let me give you an example which
suggests the duration and the
concentration of the calcium signaling
matters and it matters because the
duration and the concentration might
differentially activate different
enzymes inside the cytoplasm for example
here we consider about a calcium signal
which is very narrow in point of time to
last for a few millisecond but a huge
amount of calcium elevation and then
that is read by that is read by cam k2
now you must be wondering that at a
molecular level how this concentration
of the calcium could be recorded or how
selectively cam k2 can extract the
information from this spatial temporal
dynamics so cam k to exist in an active
form
now when it has calcium and interacts
with calcium and Cal Moodle it gets into
its activated state but also there is a
reversible reaction
triggered by calcineurin which is also a
calcium dependent phosphatase which
would bring back camp k2 to a partially
inactivated state now when there is a
sudden high rise in the calcium level
for a very small duration of time there
is a burst of CAM k2 activity and there
is a huge amount of calcium calmodulin
binding to the camp k2 which leads to
phosphorylation in a cooperative fashion
in all the subunits now this overrides
the this overrides the phosphatase
activity of calcineurin now calcineurin
can only be coat the calcium signals
which are for long duration in a shorter
duration calcineurin would be also
active but the activity of cam and cam
k2 interaction would overwrite the
calcineurin active activity and as a
result cam k2 would be activated and
that is how we can understand at a
molecular level how time and
concentration of the calcium signaling
is encoded now question is when there is
a increase in calcium level does the
calcium level increase for a long time
point of time or is there mechanism by
which the short or temporarily
restricted elevation of the calcium
could be maintained inside the cell so
it turns out in case of neurons when
action potential reaches the terminal it
releases neurotransmitters such as
glutamate glutamate allows calcium
influx by NMDA receptors
now when the calcium level increases
suddenly calcium dependent kind
kindnesses and calmodulin sequester
calcium and the rest of the calcium is
quickly channeled into endoplasmic
reticulum by Sarka pumps or pumped out
extruded from the dendritic spine by
plasma membrane ATP ASE's
that is why these extrusion mechanisms
which are extremely fast ensures that a
high level of calcium elevation lasts
only for a few millisecond
and this meant this high level of
calcium for few millisecond has an
important role important message inside
it which could be decoded by other
cellular decoders which is very which
convey a very different message for a
long-term elevation of calcium so that
is how the calcium extrusion mechanism
is also important for shaping the
calcium dynamics since we talked about
the calcium concentration in the
cytoplasm and its effect on the calcium
signaling and widespread activity on the
cellular signaling so we should also
talk about how the holistic in a
holistic manner organelles can also
modulate calcium level in the cytoplasm
organelles like mitochondria and
endoplasmic reticulum has specific
channels which allow calcium to enter so
mitochondria could work like a calcium
sink whenever there is a increase in
calcium mitochondria can buffer that
calcium and that has a different
cellular outcome endoplasmic reticulum
owner at the hand side also has this
kind of calcium intruding mechanism just
like IP through receptor also it has the
Circa pumps inside that which can pump
in calcium so that is how several
organelles also play a vital role to
modulate calcium dynamics inside the
cell I hope you enjoyed this video if
you liked this video give it a big
thumbs up don't forget to Like share and
subscribe thank you